You want a deck that all Magic players
can identify with. Unpopular, pedantic,
and has a bit of an identity crisis. I
got you. Gatilda and Lear. You know,
I've always complained about these
legend designs that seem to be doing
multiple barely related things at once.
Barely being the key word here because
once in a while you find the point of
intersection between those effects and
you strike gold. Persistent petitioners.
Human. Slime against humanity. Spell.
Boom. Human and slime. How do we get
them to work together? We ram hard to
drop some slimes and then petition to
drop more slimes. It's sweet because
slime counts exile, too. Pretty quickly,
you'll be dropping game-ending threats
with just a few casts. And of course,
the mill is useful as well. We don't
just mill more slimes into the grave.
There are also a ton of other spells
that are sweet for flashing pack from
ramp to card draw. And eventually, we
win with big creature synergies, plus
one counter synergies, and of course,
throwing stone. To start things off,
we're doing 16 petitioners and 16
slimes. That's half of our non-land card
slots taken. This is going to be a quick
one. Once again, we're going deep here.
What is the payoff? That's the question.
Unfortunately, most of the no deck limit
payoffs are in black and red. But of
course, there's always thrming stone
again. And lock it of yesterday's will
quickly reduce both slime and
petitioners down to one mana each. Spell
weaver's helix will allow us to get some
sweet sorceries over and over and over
when we cast our slimes. Imagine this
one. might as well wave your entire play
group goodbye because you will never be
invited back again. But it's worth it.
Aside from that, we're going heavy on
counters and large creature synergy. But
let's go by utility. Ram Kodama of the
West Tree is the standout here. Should
be able to quickly get our basics onto
the field. We're also playing a bunch of
the traditional ramp spells as what
we're doing here can be very mana
inensive and we won't be keeping up with
other decks without the extra mana. for
card draw with a decent board. Golden
Ratio should be able to refill our hand
for just three mana. Bread for the hunt
is made for this deck. Garuk's uprising
gives us much needed evasion in the mid
game onwards and every slime by then
should become three mana countries.
Return of the Wild Speaker and Momentous
Fall are also great once we have a
little bit of buildup. Inspiring Call is
a protection spell, but never hesitate
to just fire it off for three to four
cards. It's already an excellent rate.
Shamanic Revelation is perfect for decks
that are going kind of tall and kind of
wide like this one. The life gain will
also be immense. Lastly, Tesar's Gambit
for some draw smoothing and
proliferation. For other utility, of
course, doubling season does wonders
here. Doubling the number of tokens and
their power. Curse of the ransacked lab
for reducing mana cost and with the help
of that, unlocking it with four spells
is very doable. Another great cost
reduction spell is the Earth Crystal. It
not only works well with our slimes, but
also doubles the counters. seems perfect
here. Heroic Intervention for just one
more piece of protection. And of course,
Simic ascendancy. Yeah, let's be honest.
This is not the best card, but one win
with this counts as two, maybe three
depending on your house rules. I don't
usually play Wonder, but we're doing a
lot of self mill here and flying slimes
just seems like nightmare fuel. And for
board wipes, we are playing the most
synergistic ones. Wave goodbye of
course, but there's also Deming Verdict.
Austster command is also great here
because often times you can just choose
to wipe large creatures and protect your
entire board. Now, for lands, we are
going really heavy on MDFC spells
because I mean, if you draw them,
they're lands, but if you mill them, you
can always flash them back with your
petitioners. So, that seems like great
synergy. And aside from that, we have
some with a generic utility lands and
alchemist refuge, which is probably my
favorite land of all time. And that's
the deck. It is fairly simple and
straightforward to play. Now, the list I
included below is one without budget
limitations, but most of that cost is in
lands, and those are easily replaceable.
So, this list should be buildable for a
few hundred. Now, in terms of play
experience, this deck will not be super
fast, especially in the early game when
your slimes are two twos and three
threes, but that won't be for long.
Pretty quickly, they will grow enough to
be able to threaten your opponents and
also work with our synergy pieces. And
in terms of resilience, I think this
deck should be fairly resilient just
because if even if everything gets
cleared, your graveyard, your board, the
slime top deck will still be three mana
88, three mana 9. And that's the deck. I
know it's pretty quick, partly thanks to
having 16 copies of the same card twice.
And also, this kind of deck tack I'm
trying because, you know, it's quick,
straight to the point, and you can get a
decent idea for the deck in around five
minutes. And please let me know if this
is the kind of content you like, and
like and subscribe to not miss future
videos. And I'll see you.